good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Monday hope
everybody had a great gorgeous
fantabulous weekend and speaking of
fantabulous and
fantabulosity it is
jacqu wow oh my God hi tury I I wasn't
expecting that I just got like so
excited that I I lost my breath and I
and I choked so are you breathless for
me I'm breathless tury makes me
breathless but no I am feeling gorgeous
and fantabulous my weekend was all of
those things that's so good I'm feeling
renewed as we head into the week this is
such an exciting week because tur's
coming to town soon so it's the week of
the Super Bowl it's the week of the
Super Bowl the week of the turd and I'm
just like kind of prepping my life for
my tury oh my God you are yeah like oh
no I changed your sheets last week so
we're good on that but I need to charge
your blinds in your room I just have
like a running list of things I need
restock my mini fridge the mini fridge
is actually going to come into my room
for bottles in the night if that's okay
oh wow she's being demoted she yeah and
I just feel like you didn't even need it
no I didn't need it I enjoyed it or use
it did you even use it it was full when
I there were sodas in there no I I
[__] it up with some sodas okay maybe
I'll have to get another mini fridge
then yeah maybe like a little bit bigger
the one you got is like a skincare
fridge it could fit like three cans yeah
why did I get oh I got that fridge just
for bottles in the night just for like
when I was haking just to put it in the
fridge next to my bed it didn't need to
be B
um so if you are tuning in today which
obviously you are because the toast is
the most important platform on the
planet um you might notice where Audio
Only and that's because the turds Ville
is extremely under the weather and like
like you said it's a big week she's
headed down to Florida she can't be
getting these kids sick so I'm like in
recovery mode I am really sick and I'm
really upset because I love to be in
studio you know how it kills me not to
get my vertical videos I know especially
for a day such as this when there is so
much to talk about I watch the Grammys
for from start to finish last night me
too I enjoyed myself
immensely I'm kind of just like in my
era of enjoying like mainstream popular
things I feel like honestly you were
definitely like in your hater era for
like a really long time but I feel like
I feel like I've come so full circle
from like being critical of things that
now I'm just like my expectations are so
low for stuff and I can just enjoy it no
but also I think everyone would agree
like the Grammys were particularly
fabulous last night in terms of like
people who showed up in terms of the
performances Trevor Noah was not
offensive like it was good it was good
it wasn't even about the star quality
because there were there's always like
big stars it just depends on who you
prioritize but just something about it
was good the music was good the jokes
were good Trevor Noah had me chuckling
yeah he was cute he stayed on topic yep
I think it's like his third year doing
the Grammy finally like got it right I
don't know who wrote his jokes last
night but they should be hired out for
the other award shows it's like how do
we make a joke about just this award
show and make it fun Chu chuckle it's
not like the best most amazing jokes
I've ever heard in my entire life like
chuckle chuckle chuckled it was the best
of times it was the worst of times
chuckle chuckle got a chuckle for me so
of course Today's show is going to be
major recap of the Grammys the fashion
the awards the performances the Luke
Holmes of it all the Taylor Swift of it
all so we have a really fun and exciting
show but before we dive in J tell me
about
you about me so weaning cabbage land is
going according to plan it actually the
Cabbage brought my Supply down so much
like I wasn't ready to be done yet and a
little too well yeah and I'm not done
and I also I was out this weekend so I
didn't do cabbage I did the Cabbage
cream which definitely helps but it's
not as rapid as the Cabbage which is
okay because like I could go for still
another week of like just nursing
morning and night and nothing in between
so that kind of took up my weekend but I
I also had just like it was really nice
weather here on Saturday so we hit the
pool it was just a really fun fun
weekend like I know that everyone does
like cabbage it's like a age-old thing
but like it's giving homesteading
tradwife I know and that's might be why
I love it nobody loves it though more
than Bruno because every once in a while
I drop a piece or I left a piece on my
bedside table Bruno and he waits and
he's so I feel like he's like Edward and
Twilight being around Bella and like not
eating her love that reference is Bruno
sleeping with me last night he was
cuddled in my bosom and I know it took
every ounce of willpower for him not to
eat mommy's cabbage stop that's like so
sweet I forget that you have a dog like
how nice for you I know but he's going
to be our dog in just a week I know I
can't wait to see him he's been so
amazing I'm so glad you brought this up
I was you actually brought it up but
continue I was co-sleeping with Bryson
last night as we were watching C and not
chuckling more on that later okay so me
and Ben started curb after the Grammys
but I was like I got to go to sleep and
it was like not keeping me it
was good yeah it was especially for a
season opener right and they like picked
up right where they left off at the end
of the last
season love Maria Sophia but I'm like
who is this woman living with Larry oh
yeah I thought you were going to be like
chuckling over JG Wentworth oh like that
was like
cute thing took a dumb funny joke yeah
me and Ben would write not Larry David
yeah I thought it was all like really
bad and stupid except Maria Sophia stole
the show as she always does okay I'm
obsessed with the Maria Sophia storyline
it's it's actually so funny I had
forgotten about her I like forgot what
the show was about these days and then
Maria Sophia takes over the world and I
love that for her love and like when she
did that fake Jimmy Kimmel interview she
was being so funny no she she she's
hysterical she's a star and I was
co-sleeping nestling up with Bruno last
night and I was just I was having a
Bruno Renaissance moment where I was
like this boy and he's turning three and
a half this month and it just time flies
it's my eldest boy he's such a he's
grown into such a lovely young man Bruno
is turning three and a half that's you
know half of Theo's
life yeah just
about not even actually Theo was not
even seven so the was six and a
half
yeah and he when he was stolen from us
when he was
murdered yeah so crazy I can't get in
peace King rip King so yes I think we
should just dive in because honestly
like I have so much to say about the
Grammys wait before we do how was your
influence her weekend oh my God I I
haven't even spoken to you I don't even
know how it went how did it go brokering
peace amongst the influencers so I kind
of threw myself like a little dinner
party well not myself but you know you
called up your favorite influencers well
tinx was in town she was like should we
get dinner I'm like yes but also
Shannon's in town so maybe you two could
officially like me they've never even
met and then I was like let's just get
like the girlies together and like who
does tins know who should tins know who
would tin Vibe with and we had such a
good meal at ao's Bato like the best
Italian food ever chicken parm so good
and the girls just girl like I kind of
just sat back and watched you know like
my work come to life mhm and it was so
much fun we had drinks we had dinner we
went out for cocktails after we ran into
the
snatchler the snatchler she why didn't
she get the invite to the dinner it was
just kind of like an older girl older
sister thing you know I totally
understand she's like she's too young no
she's like my little sister yeah no and
it was for like the mature influencers
it was for the older sisters like yeah
we're women in our 30s I hear you loud
and clear but then we walked into did
she even notice or was she infected no
honestly I haven't spoken to her because
I've been like so sick but I meant to
call her and be like that was weird
running into you like like a regular
person like I literally walked into
zeron and she was right there waiting
for the elevator I was like oh my God
and then we spent the night together but
I was like that's like so weird we
weren't like texting that's so weird
yeah it was just kind of like with my
cool older friends you know yeah totally
and who was she with her younger friends
and did you guys join forces yeah of
course we had a big table oh how fun and
then we like ran into some other people
we knew so it was kind of like fabulous
night to be in New York yeah no it
sounds that way it was B I'll get the
full recap offline oh yeah and then I
woke up so sick and it's just been like
downhill ever since yeah well I'm sure I
don't want to sound like you know the
teacher but I'm sure I'm sure the
drinking and The Hangover doesn't help
the sick I didn't
drink you looked like classic drunk tury
no I didn't drink I don't drink alcohol
I could see in those eyes I said that
girl is gone she's Gone Girl she's
holding it together she's going going
gone I love that yeah I see you it was
really fun so good to you know have my
my friends who are like sisters in New
York with me you
know but not your sisters who are like
friends no no honestly I you're becoming
one of those people who's like my
friends are my family Jackie my friends
are my family like
stop but my family are my friends of
course except for Maro
no no honestly I need to call her
because like it was so regular do you
know what I mean like walking into an
establishment and seeing my this my
flesh and blood and I was like I was
like what are you doing here she really
crazy for us who like have tabs on each
other we all like have each other's
locations we know what everyone and
where everyone is at all points of Life
yeah so like Margo I guess just like had
plans that night I had plans that night
so we didn't like contact one another
and then I I was like oh my God I just
feel like I'm like a person who's like
like distant from my family you know
totally it's giving distant from your
family it's giving like cut it's giving
like Jordan Roger no actually Aaron
Rogers like the two of them just like
running into each other at a football
game no seriously like now that we don't
talk now that we don't talk so the Super
Bowl is this weekend I'm so excited
we're getting like already like footage
and stuff everybody's landed in Vegas
it's so exciting I bought myself a
t-shirt to wear on Super Bowl Sunday
because I was placing an order I just
want to say shout out I got a bunch of
stuff from abomi delivered this morning
I was trying it on before the show
everything was a sleigh I got they have
like really cute sports clothes so I got
a 49ers t-shirt to wear for the big game
oh I saw that they had released a
collection of like NFL stuff and I went
to go purchase it and I thought like all
the teams had such cute stuff except
like the 49ers one was kind of ugly yeah
that's how I felt too but like I needed
a shirt so I'm going to bring my jersey
oh right you have swag I have assigned
Kyle use Che Jersey it says from not it
says from one toaster to another so like
I'll probably just wear that you know
just like chill girl Vibes it's not like
Ben's pen has one too oh he he worth it
twice yeah we we have like multiple sign
jerseys you know he didn't write though
from one good guy to another it was
before the good guys this was like over
a year ago those were the
days kind of like one of my favorite
like toast lore things is us like having
one-sided beef with the good guys like
they don't even listen they don't even I
was trying to explain it to Ben he's
like we don't care no I'm obsessed with
us like just having beef with everyone
we have beef with good guys we have beef
with smartless we do have beef with
smart let's [__] them actually that's
kind of where our beef starts T I feel
like everyone else we have mad respect
for like we have respect for Tom sugura
we have respect for Tim Dylan we have
respect for theovon we have major
respect for Joe Rogan we're going to
talk about that later jagie do we have
respect for Tom seura because we didn't
really even talk about like how we were
snubbed snubbed Beyond like we put Bert
and Tom in our [__] title it just
goes to show you they don't look at the
charts not that they snubbed us I don't
know what's worse that like we look at
the charts so much and like it didn't
occur to us that other people didn't or
that they literally saw it and ignored
us what's worse I don't know I don't
know either but I do have respect for
them until I know that it's an official
snubbing I just feel like The Vibes are
good and I love Tom's
book I just feel like and B went on good
guys so technically like that's family
to
us as much as we beat but Jack we're
distant from our family
as much as we beef with good guys like
if someone goes on good guys like
they're good with us I F I oh no and if
as much as we beef with good guys like
you can't like I can talk it about Good
Guys you can't what oh I'm sorry I
wasn't saying you I was saying like we
can oh like the like like they're our
family like we can say what we want but
at the end of the day it's like blood is
thicker than water [__] yeah no but
like you if you come for good guys like
we come for your neck exactly but I
thought you were taking away my joy no
no no no please talk come for good guys
all you want okay cool yeah and also I
feel like if you have beef with someone
you could veto them going on Good Guys
right you have like final say if you
need I have I have veto power yes have
you used have you exercised his power no
cuz one thing about the good guys is
like they're not going to run things by
me like they just do their thing and
like I find out with everybody else you
know so true it's better that way but I
guess Ben like knows who I hate so he
would be like he would never have you
know Scott rowski on right and it's not
like a huge list it's very small exive
Scott rowski like who I would truly stop
and from having on the podcast yeah no
one really in like the influencer
reality TV space stop him from having on
except Scott
row yeah but you're giving him too much
credit that he would even get books like
alongside the inv it's so true yeah so
true um okay let's dive in because we
really have a lot of ground to cover
today yeah hold on tight like this is
going to be a long one there's so much
to say so without further adoo here are
the fast stories that you need to know
so our first story is actually brought
to you by McDonald's and we're going to
do a big Grammy's fashion recap it is
time for a very special segment where we
are going to discuss the best Lukes on
the Grammy's red carpet and this very
glamorous segment is brought to you by
McDonald's so as the lovely toasters
know we recently partnered with
McDonald's to talk about their classic
Burgers which are hotter juicier and
tastier than ever and we are once asking
again for justice for the Hamburglar
because who could blame him for trying
to steal a Big Mac McDonald's patties
are cooked to Juicy Perfection and the
cheese is perfectly melted pillowy soft
golden bun a Big Mac that now has more
special sauce in every bite what more
could you ask for in honor of the
Hamburglar and his very understandable
attempts to steal McDonald's hamburgers
today we're going to be talking about
which looks stole the red carpet from
the Grammy's red carpet everybody showed
up and showed out last night um run me
through some of your favorites okay I'm
going to start on a positive because
we're we're extremely positive here yep
Miley loved I loved everything about
Miley last night her energy and her Aura
and the hair the dress she just owned
every element of what she was wearing
and love 10 out of 10 T across the board
the dress was a 10 out of 10 for sure
the hair was different different like
would I wear the hair no but does does
it work for this era Miley's like
currently in yes it was different it was
giving like lioness mullet and it was
very Miley agreed I wouldn't wear it but
it was flowing you know who looked
amazing who did not get to walk the red
carpet because there was like apparently
a crazy rainstorm in La was Kelsey
ballerini yes always which sucks because
she looked so pretty I loved her dress
and she posted a bunch of pictures on
Instagram yeah but we didn't get to see
and her Glam was beautiful but she
always she knows her dress what did you
think about Olivia Rodrigo who wore
vintage and who by the way was styled by
something Navy sister do you know that
no I didn't know that and I think she
looks beautiful I love a classic look I
love it just going for a gorgeous
classic look with a red lip and a hair
down and a side part like you can't go
wrong with that by me no that's very
true okay then we also have ice spice
who was giving classic ice spice she was
giving classic ice spice she looked
adorable like definitely different no
one else is wearing something even
remotely similar in terms of like attire
but I thought she looked super cute yeah
she looked really cute the Grammys is
also like a red carpet where you're
supposed to have fun while also looking
nice I feel like this is a really good
example of that and I think sometimes
people play it safe on the red carpet I
like a safe classic look but also like
when you go outside of the box and and
you nail it one of my best dress was
Sophia Richie like classic understated
so like beautiful pregnant woman I
thought she looked great same and
Christina agilera I love I agree that
blue was Goran love this color love how
it's styled I love her Loki I love her
so much she's doing a Las Vegas
residency right now and like I need to
go we also speaking of Las Vegas and
women in music need to talk about Kelly
who's stunned in a white in a white gown
the queen was stuned as she always does
she brought her son with her he looked
so cute Kelly looked amazing like I feel
like Kelly was just there to have fun
she was just living her best life she
wasn't taking it too seriously I thought
she looked amazing I agree and I hope
she had all of those things another
outfit that I loved was Chrissy tan
loved her dress oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think Paris hton looked amazing too like
that color she really kind of like Paris
Sulton always slays yeah always slays
knows what work for her like doesn't try
and reinvent the wheel and I I
appreciate that oh I'm looking at this
Ellie Golding was there I missed her but
I love her I was looking also this
morning I didn't even see Ellie Golding
I thought she looked amazing but
literally only on this red carpet recap
link that I was just looking at is the
first time I saw her and that's a shame
because when Ellie ging is in the
building you pay respect and they didn't
no they did not not at all I would love
an Ellie ging
performance I would love an Ellie ging
performance too I feel like everybody um
really looked very nice last night I
feel like sometimes these award shows
can be like a little cooky like
everybody tries so hard to out do one
another I thought everybody just looked
like really glamorous really pretty very
um glamorous that's the word lovely they
looked lovely I loved Beyonce's look too
you know it was very we didn't get red
carpet we didn't get red carpet photos
of her either so we really didn't get to
see the whole look but I love her in a
cowboy hat yeah I thought it was great
people on Twitter were saying that
Beyonce was get and Karen
Huger I do see the comparison oh what
did you think about Casey mus Graves I'm
looking at her right now so there's
nothing wrong with it but it didn't like
I didn't love it it's plain yeah but
she's an elegant Queen she is an elegant
Queen and she really can't do any wrong
I love scissors dress and I also love
that she put it back on after her
performance cuz like that's how much she
must have liked it too 100% like not a
thousand outfit changes yeah usually
after people perform they put on like
their next outfit which makes sense
you're not going to like put on your
your previous dress but if you love your
previous dress keep wearing it I also
just imagine like the feeling of being
like in that dress any dress for so many
hours and then like being done with the
award show taking it off and like going
to McDonald's like that is probably the
best part of the night win or lose the
drive-thru is the best part of the night
100% Yesterday Zach dropped me off for a
manicure pedicure and when he picked me
up he had McDonald's waiting for me in
the car and it was just one of those
moments where it was it was one of those
moments was good so thanks so much to
McDonald's for sponsoring the special
Grammy segment they are truly um these
are truly McDonald's best classic
burgers ever so try McDonald's best
burgers ever at a McDonald's near you so
I personally I would say my best dressed
if you had to name one person Montana
Tucker Oh agreed love love she wore a
ribbon on her chest saying bring them
home as an homage to the hostages that
are still in Gaza that everyone has just
forgotten about forgotten about I agree
and also like the dress was beautiful
too like I actually thought she amaz oh
my God she looked amazing yeah it really
was like very star studded I feel like
with the Grammys specifically I feel
like so many people don't go so many
artists have like beef with the Grammys
and we'll talk about that with like
Jay-Z's speech Drake has been very vocal
about his beef with the grammies I feel
like a lot of times like big big movers
and shakers don't all go the same year
and I feel like this particular year we
got a lot I don't feel like we even got
a lot this year but I feel like we got
the handful that I personally appreciate
but I and care about yeah I don't feel
like it was a hugely stared year and I
actually felt like the nominees like
this they weren't it wasn't the
strongest year of nominees ever like
nobody swept I feel like if know Adele
didn't come out with an album not Bruno
Mars or Beyonce or anyone just the
Taylor Swift Midnight's album which for
some reason I didn't think was going to
sweet maybe because anti-hero was the
song that was up for nomination and I
don't think that is even clo that's
probably like the worst song on the
album like imagine if Mastermind was
nominated it would have won everything
Agreed 100% it was not not very
competitive and that's why like I didn't
think midnights was going to win but
when it did s should have won honestly I
I I really believe that like just in
terms of that the album in particular
like yeah this was Taylor's Big Year and
the album is amazing and it's not not
deserving but like really it was like
sz's year but's so funny is I listen to
Midnight's backwards and forwards is
probably my most listened to album of
course after getting old by Luke Holmes
which was the snub of the century SN of
the but no I loved midnight so much I
couldn't stop listening to it and yet
weirdly I still didn't think it was
album of the year I don't know why I
don't know why I have like a grudge
against midnights by the way I I don't
even have a grudge against midnights I
love midnights I feel like with all of
Taylor's success this year it wasn't
really even about midnights that's why I
felt like it it wasn't going to win
because every like yes this is the year
of Taylor Swift Time person of the year
the era St y y I feel like all of that
success like kind of has nothing to do
with midnights it that is also true but
I feel like I even listen to midnights
more than you I can't explain it I
listen to it I love it so much but it
didn't register for me as album of the
year until she won I'm like oh duh like
I think of all the songs that are on it
and I'm like how is that not album of
the year I don't think she thought she
was going to win either because she made
her big announcement when she won pop
vocal which like is not like the most
important Grammy ever it's not like we
would make a big announcement for but I
think she was certain that if she was
going to win any was just going to be
that one yeah well let's go through the
show oh wait let's also what did you
think about Taylor's uh outfit I
disliked it yeah I very much disliked it
we we have gotten to a point point where
like we've really we've done all that we
can do like with this particular stylist
like I do feel like Taylor needs a new
style mood board she just needs someone
to come in and like start from scratch
she is literally any designer in the
world would die die die die die die die
to work with her like I feel like you we
were texting and you said this like it's
almost like it's harder for her to look
bad with all the resources she's so
beautiful and she's got you know yeah
like I don't want to sound like you know
she's got a great great figure she's a
beautiful woman she has the access to
all the connections and resources in the
world she actually has to go out of her
way to look bad which it feels like
she's doing no to me like last night's
outfit was a huge mess I feel like most
of the time she doesn't really look bad
she just looks so safe and it's like
come on we can be doing so much more I
felt like last night's was bad last
night's was a miss and the dress itself
is a nice looking dress and I think if
she had worn just the dress with a
different hairstyle her Glam is always
on point like sheate and I Lov her
makeup if she wore just the dress and
kept it really simple I think that would
have been really pry I didn't like the
gloves I didn't like the hair I liked
the necklaces I'm fine with those I
loved the necklaces actually I did not
like the hair and altogether it was bad
it was and it's it feels
intentional yeah maybe it's like an
attempt at relatability honestly
like or just like an attempt at like oh
you want me to play like the pretty
princess no yeah but like she is still a
pretty princess wearing a big gown do
you know what I
mean I
do take gloves off for her speech her
final speech which was very good better
that was good okay yeah so let's do run
of show between like performances Awards
and just like General moments Miss like
first let's talk about Trevor Noah as
stated the joke goods were funny I was
chuckling there was nothing offensive
and he stayed on topic that's really all
you have to do and that's why when I say
like I don't feel bad for Joe Koy it's
an easy job especially if you're a
comedian this is your trade no and
Trevor Noah I think did like a little
bit of improv cuz like people kept
walking in and I thought those were the
funniest parts like that's real talent I
thought he did a very good job I agree
and you could tell he did improv from
when people were walking in and he was
writing jokes about that and I thought
that was impressive and and he did good
it's it's as simple as that right the
thing with the host is like we're not
supposed to have like a ton to say he's
just supposed to sort of like get the
show from beginning to end us through
and that's it and I feel like he did a
good job like me and Ben chuckled a few
times it was good it was good then I
think the first big Award of the night
went to Miley for pop vocal song flowers
I was so happy for her obviously you
guys know I've been up and down with
Miley through the years but it's crazy
how growing up she was my everything in
this world and I can't I I don't ever
forget that and when I see her like a
part of me goes back to that place and
seeing her last night thriving and
winning I was so so happy for her yeah
she deserves it flowers is an amazing
song but just I just loved her energy I
really did and I was so glad to see her
win yeah what I really liked about Miley
is I feel like everyone in that room
like takes themselves so seriously and
they're so competitive and like
everybody has such a big ego and
everyone's just trying to be so cool and
I feel like Miley was there she's like
yeah I've never w a Grammy like she was
so happy to be there so excited like
really just didn't give a [__] and she
was like so unserious about the whole
thing when sometimes it's like calm down
you guys it's an award show I feel like
her her like her Outlook was really
healthy and she looked like she was
having so much fun nobody was having
more fun than Miley and that's always
going to be the person who looks the
coolest I loved her performance I loved
the Improv it started off weird when she
was like why you guys acting like you
don't know this song God Jackie I like
that's jokoy my my biggest pet peeve is
when people do that when she stopped in
the middle of the performance I was like
why guys acting like you don't know the
song she didn't stop and I feel like she
likes to do a bit of like Cabaret
talking through her songs so she it it
was I forgot about it because the rest
of the performance was so good
especially when she was like I just won
my first Grammy and of course the whole
time I'm thinking about like Liam
Hemsworth the song is about him like
this was a low point when she wrote this
song and now she's she's winning yeah no
it was a triumphant evening like she
really she she was so happy and she's so
talented and her voice is so good and I
love when she gets to stunt on everyone
in the room it's like oh you don't take
me seriously but like here I go yeah no
she reminded everyone like she really is
such a talented vocalist and there's
like this running joke on social media
that like the three pop girlies who
still don't have Grammys are Katy Perry
Nicki Minaj and Miley sis and like
people were making these hilarious memes
being like Miley leaving the room of
like the and it's like when she leaves
the house in Hannah Montana that she
grew up and she's like waving it's so
funny but really Miley's just been one
of those girls who like hasn't had a
Grammy and she totally deserved it every
time she was nominated I knew she was
going to win I didn't think the album
should have won and it didn't but I
think that song like was really the song
of the year I also really appreciated
Mark Ronson and Merl Streep explaining
the difference between song of the year
and record of the year which is
something I've never understood but now
I get and I do think song of the year if
it's about the songwriting Billy ish
what was I made for I was listening that
last night was the first time I heard
the song in full and I was thinking
about the lyrics Because by the way I
did watch Barbie and I hopefully I'll
get to my recap today but if not it
could wait till tomorrow because we have
a lot to talk about today but I was just
in awe of the lyrics how it's like a
song about finding yourself but it's
also a song about being a doll turning
into a
human okay wait I'm sorry I need to know
your thoughts on Barbie like just quick
please I liked it I told you you would
like there's nothing not to like now we
could talk about like where everyone's
gotone wrong with Barbie and I think
people are putting way too much stock
into it and if I do want to like go
through the messaging of the movie like
I think they don't even know what the
message was I think there were so many
contradictions and like they don't even
know what they're trying to say yet
they're saying it so heavy-handedly I'm
like okay what
um it needed to end 25 minutes earlier
than it did like it dragged on so much
but like I enjoyed it it just gets a
little dicey when it's like now this is
the movie of the year the Oscar movie
like no it's not it's it was just a fun
movie right right right it was just
meant to be fun like everyone's taking a
little too seriously when it's just a a
lovely light-hearted fun movie about a
plastic doll yeah okay
jooy oh a plastic doll was with boobies
no like it's about a do it's Barbie like
come on let's keep it funet let's keep
it fun and keep it moving no and for
sure and by the way and like I agree I
think the message was so confusing like
I don't even know what the takeaway was
but you know these under by the way
people will say yeah you didn't get it
Claudia by the way I just want you to
know there was no cohesive message it
was inherently contradictory and they
didn't know what they wanted to say and
they didn't know how to end the [__]
movie but there are these like really
sweet sort of themes of like girlhood
and all these things and that's really
sweet and I think when I when I saw the
movie like I had enjoyed it as well it's
like what the culture did with the movie
ruined it yeah all the like discourse
about it and just making it something
that it's
not what was that polarizing oh
polarizing but also just like
intellectualizing like it's not that
it's just a fun a fun movie and I think
also the people involved in it like
really want it to be taken seriously too
but it's like no it's not that serious
I'm sorry but I I really enjoyed it and
I just want to say I disagree with you
in that I think I'm just Ken was so good
oh and I like the I like the beat and I
think it deserves to be nominated over
dance the night it was like doing
something different and I hope Ryan
Gosling performs at the Oscars which is
still up I he is no Mark Ronson said he
didn't know we also um wanted to Circle
back on something from the show last
week remember we started that list of
random topics that became polarizing
Barbie movie yes and couldn't remember
it was the Detroit Lions fans they were
like if you said like you were happy
that the Niners won it's like you're
disra like they were being insane I'll
add it to the list though like NFL is
polarizing no but this took it to like
another really unhinged level yeah okay
it's on the list no worries thank you
okay so back to and then the second
performance and then dualipa opened
which she was good and fine and whatever
um Luke Holmes Luke Holmes was so cute
and you know that I've said like it's
not my favorite song on the album fast
car because it it's not luky enough for
me and I like Luke songs that sound like
Luke songs but seeing the whole package
last night gave me such an appreciation
Tracy Chapman sounded amazing people
were freaking like in the audience like
everyone was bugging it's like they had
announced that this performance was
going to happen I feel like nobody knew
because it was dark and then the song
started playing and then the lights came
up on Tracy Chapman and people like
gasped yeah no it was it was so good it
was clearly such a full circle moment
for Luke and for her to be performing
this song that you know had its time and
its Heyday and now it's having a whole
Renaissance I thought it was so awesome
and it really brought so many people
together because everybody loves that
song and Luke is like you know the king
of country but now we're all enjoying
this moment like there's not one person
I think on Earth who didn't enjoy that
moment no no I honestly like I had tears
in my eyes it was first of all for Trac
chman AG this collab could unite the
world no it's so true and like the stats
about this collab like I was reading
today like Tracy Chapman has a number
she's the first black woman to have a
number one country song because she's
the sole writer on this song I was
trying to explain these historical stats
to Zach and he was like no the song
pascar was huge when it came out I'm
like no I know but it's doing new things
and it's doing new things to a totally
different audience and like a different
genre different generation like and I
thought his perform the performance was
so good I feel like Luke really was
trying so hard not to like step on her
toes sing with like he just really
wanted her to have her moment it was so
amazing and seeing when every time they
pan to the crowd like I was freaking I
was loving watching like seeing other
people receive the the performance like
Taylor like singing to Luke Holmes like
I could like it was too much yeah it was
too much who's Sayang the line about the
checkout girl
Luke I I literally when he Sayang it I
was like thinking of you interesting
choice I feel like they actually say
that line a few times I feel like they
both said it multiple times they were
both the checkout girl and and it's a
long song and they let them sing the
whole song like it was really it was
magical I like that about the
performances that they weren't rush and
there were so many performances where I
felt like I wanted more like I loved how
Miley went into Tina Turner maybe she
didn't get the memo that Fantasia Bina
was doing like a whole thing doing it
yeah but I mean I can't get enough of
that song I wanted more Miley yeah no
Miley and she was being like a character
and she was just like she had just won
her first Grammy like I imagine that was
probably like the most fun she's ever
had and she always has fun but then I
also liked in Her speech even though it
didn't like come off exactly I think as
how she meant it which was like these
things don't mean so much yeah it gave a
little bit like ungrateful like you're
not going to be winning again anytime
soon now that you've just pissed off Mr
Grammy also you know noteworthy that she
thanked everyone in her family except
her dad yeah there's drums there's drum
and she has a new man who has that hair
who inspired the hair she has a new man
who has that hair it's it's so true what
you say it's kind of all it's all I know
about them I was going to say it's all
you need to know but maybe there's other
stuff I don't know but it's all I know
about them is the hair yeah his
hair which inspired her hair which I
liked it's
hair yeah there's hair
voler um other performances that I loved
Billy Joel first of all I feel like we
were saying on the toast how like Billy
Joel is like such a legend in New York
but I feel like the music industry like
doesn't respect him so having them like
make a whole big thing of him coming
like I loved I'm so happy for him that
new song was so cute I loved that story
with the songwriter like Billy Joel was
like I don't want to release music
anymore but then this guy was like
hounding him to do it I thought it was
so cute the song was good and then they
also let him perform he performed twice
he also sang you know during the credits
which I loved yeah that was a a cute
thing yeah what other
performances oh Olivia rrio oh we'll get
to Travis Scott yeah let's continue on
the positives Olivia Rodrigo um I
thought she sounded great you're always
so hard on her I I have very very high
expectations for Olivia red rgo vocally
and the last two times I've heard her
sing vampire which is a very tough song
to sing on SNL she was really bad and I
didn't think so this time like I just
thought she could have done better I
just feel like her I I have very very
high standards for her vocally you do
maybe you have high higher expectations
for her cuz you're like closer to it and
me a little zoomed out I'm like this
overall is a really beautiful
performance and I think that she
totally
like what's the
word holds her own in that
room by the way she definitely holds her
own in that room yeah but it's a tough
room it is a tough room she was good she
wasn't bad at all but like I just I I
think vocally she no and I say this as
someone of course with perfect pitch I
just feel like she could have done
better like that's it Dam turty damn
damn turty Billy eyh Perfection I really
like that song only because I've been
just hearing it now for the first time
Fantasia burino doing the Tina Turner um
obsess tribute obsessed and I was just
thinking of Kelly in the room and they
did show Kelly um towards the end
because they're sisters in American Idol
Oh so true American Idol sisters also I
read on Twitter that Fantasia burino
auditioned for American Idol to that
song so it's like real full circle
moment for her full circle moment also
Fantasia Marino's dancers they were
doing the most it was Electric
I like that was just a performance
that's like a real performance where
it's about Showmanship and those are the
things that I personally like I like
high energy I like the costumes razzled
Dazzle we're having fun we're keeping it
light like that's entertaining Dazzle
we're having fun that's Entertainment I
like to be
entertained not like morose untalented
things which we get a lot of and I
didn't feel like that's what was
happening last night which is why I
enjoyed last night I also um I'm just
now realizing they didn't really tap
Kelly for anything musically I know
Kelly I didn't know Kelly chemistry was
nominated like as it should be that
album is amazing it is amazing but I do
feel like Trevor Noah made a really
funny joke that um was very
complimentary towards Kelly which was
that like if you step out of line at the
Grammy's like we're going to have Kelly
Clarkson cover your song better than you
ever could love love love slay love slay
oh sz's performance was fabulous yeah
um now the performance that maybe you
didn't love Travis Scott was a disgrace
yeah and not even him just being there
which is a an aside um I was open you
know and sometimes the Grammys or award
shows like I'll see performances of
performance that I don't like watch
their performances all the time so I'm
like oh okay you know what I get the
hype I thought it was horrible um could
have the breaking of the chairs like
needed to have a warning for like anyone
with epilepsy ep the lights I couldn't
even look at my TV so at a certain point
I didn't even know what he was doing but
it it was it was really horrible on all
counts it
wasn't the music was there music I don't
know the chair it was bad it was
terrible it was absolutely terrible
another bad performance that was like
fake and like pre-recorded was you two
at the sphere like how dumb do they
think we are no there's nothing you two
Won't Do For a
Check there's nothing you two Won't Do
For a Check anyone who's doing like the
satellite performance so true at an
irrelevant venue or like for a sponsor
or something like those people have sold
their soul no so true you know yeah I'm
just looking through the list making
sure we didn't miss anyone um oh we need
to talk about the Carters J Mitchell oh
we do need to talk about and in there's
so much more sorry we're not even
halfway done Jonie Mitchell like I'm not
a big Joanie Mitchell fan but like I
understand like the importance of like
her being there getting a Grammy and
people getting to see her before I'm
live I'm happy for everybody who like
that meant a lot to it personally meant
nothing to me retweet on that and I do
like the message of respect your elders
agreed that's always nice what were you
going to say we need to Che the
Carters JayZ speech okay that was like
lowkey funny um like he was being funny
he was giving like Kanye Kanye energy
but like I mean that in a complimentary
way yes loved Blue Ivy on stage loved so
poised really crazy I don't think I ever
put together that Beyonce has the most
Grammys out of any artist and she's
never won album of the year like that
kind of makes no sense no I never put
that together I didn't know who he's
talking about I had to ask oh Jackie
texted me who is Jackie
texted who is Jay-Z talking about that
has all those Grammys but never won
album of the year I'm like his literal
wife that's crazy who won the year of
lemonade I don't know when I about like
her albums I feel like that's the album
that would should have won last year
when it was Renaissance Harry's house
won and I do feel like that should have
won um lemonade Beyonce you feel like
which should have won Harry's house yeah
yeah and then
2016 oh Adele and remember Adele like
said that yeah that's a really like
that's what I mean that's a tough
competitive year and I didn't feel like
there was something like that this year
me neither by the way
damn yeah I thought his speech was great
I thought it was funny it was and fresh
I feel like it was like a mic drop they
left right after that like bye yeah and
I loved seeing Beyonce showing showing
up in a cowboy hat yeah but she was also
just giving like I'm here to support my
wife who's my husband who's accepting an
award yeah which I feel like you know
everyone like every time they leave
their house like it's for Beyonce so it
was nice to like Jay-Z had a had a
moment yeah and she could just be a
supportive wife and just be herself you
know yeah what else was
there
the the CEO of the Grammys made a a nice
speech about um the Nova Music Festival
which was just nice to take a moment um
it was you know a little vague it was
bare minimum he didn't say the word
Israeli but okay or Jewish but it was
better than nothing oh and Miss Annie
Lennox who's literally now my arch
nemesis like I never thought much about
Annie Lennox but now I wake up every
morning thinking about how I can destroy
her um singing the imori and she really
sang Just awfully like really poorly and
I think that was disrespectful to the
dead and all the you know friends and
family of those we lost this year so as
if that wasn't offensive enough she then
took an opportunity
to shout like a an offensive political
statement during an immemorial that's
literally not even about her after like
disgracing everyone with her vocals
she's on my list I don't really know
this woman I was showering and I missed
it and then I didn't go back once I
heard what she said because that's just
upsetting and I was enjoying my evening
yeah and she she also just said it in
like a really weird way like vocally she
seems like a weirdo she said like
artists for ceasefire which makes no
[__] sense but I can't get into that
but she said it like this Artis FAA like
she
said she said it in a really moric story
briefly we were
crack like she was literally sounded so
weird She's A
Freak yeah
so that like almost Ru in the night for
me but other than that it actually
really was a fabulous Grammys event I
feel like everybody who put the show on
should be really proud of themselves
like it was good stuff it was good it
was positive and it was entertaining and
that's what I'm looking for we do need
to talk about one thing okay it's really
crazy how in like recent years like the
E network has so fumbled the ball like
they had one thing going for them like
it was always like they couldn't come up
with an original show they got the
Kardashians it was like the best thing
but they were always like the pop
culture Network they always had the best
red carpets they always had the best
correspondents they always had the best
journalists and
e-s they canceled E newss I don't know
why another like bringing it back but we
really need to talk about L
Cox okay so Eed carpet was like during
bedtime and I missed really the whole
thing I saw one lever Cox interview with
BB Rex and like that was it and they
were singing opera yeah but that was
kind of like BB did that yeah no but I'm
just saying like overall like lever Cox
is not a journalist she was asking for
for a makeup campaign
and she is like the official she's like
the Juliana now she's like the big one
the one the Ryan and I just feel like no
like Kelty is over there they put her in
the glambot Kelty is literally like a
20year veteran of entertainment
journalism like let her interview
someone yeah Heather McMahon did a great
job but like lever she's really like
it's this is not her skill set yeah
she's like we she ask weird questions
why there are so many people who could
actually not so many people cuz it is a
hard job but like there are a lot of
people who could get the job done I feel
like after every award show the reviews
are are not kind towards lever like I
make a CH they tried but like it's her
time yeah and they have people yeah they
have kely Justin would do a great job
Heather I saw one interview that Heather
did with someone who I didn't know and I
felt like she kept the energy like
really high considering she was hysteric
rad yeah they they there was a time
where like they employed many many
journalists and now it's like they host
they bring people in house and they like
train them a little bit but this lever
thing is just not working out like it's
really not yeah and she's the main one
she's like she's the one now that's so
weird it's so
weird well okay guess I didn't miss
anything there I'm sure like there are
things from the Grammys that we might be
missing but we'll trickle in oh I'm
sorry Taylor's album or is that a story
that's a story um okay so I'll wait also
Selen Deion arrived to present album of
the Year and that was very exciting for
everyone cuz she's been like going
through it and
um very excited to see her the gays are
really mad at Taylor Swift like
seriously they're Pitchfork like they're
mad yeah cuz she didn't acknowledge
sleam when she accepted her reward but
there was a lot going on of course there
was a lot going on and also like what we
know a lot of things about Taylor but
and what do we know she's like the most
excited overly friendly like she's not a
snubber yeah like please lizo was there
which I thought was kind of
bananas why did you think it was kind of
bananas just cuz she's like lowkey like
being sued for like sexual assault the
bananas allegations oh oh the bananas
the bananas the bananas yeah no she's
moving on like one thing about lizo was
like you want to cancel her like she
refuses to be brought down and I do I do
respect that sort of response in light
of a scandal I really do but it was
definitely Brave right but like why it's
not even about like her choice of I'm
not going to be staying down
like they invited her yeah no she was uh
she presented to
ca sisa oh my gosh sorry
I'm she is producing wait I just heard
CIA is producing a new album for someone
funny hold on
wait producing
I just read this on
Twitter oh seia I mean see oh my God I'm
I'm having a stroke parison love love
that collab of the sentury collab of the
century okay great well I feel like we
covered pretty much everything but if
there's anything that else that comes up
we'll we'll pop back into the Grammys
and I think we can dive into the next
story I think we could dive into the
next story which is still like Grammys
talks so let's get into it the rest of
today's show is brought to you by
draftking Sportsbook looking for a super
offer for Super Bowl 58 well draft King
sports book has you covered new
customers can can bet on the big game
and turn five bucks into 200 instantly
in bonus bets so download the draftking
Sportsbook app now and use code toast
new customers can bet five bucks to get
200 instantly in bonus bets only on
draftking Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the Super Bowl 58
with code toast the crown is yours
gambling problem call 1 1800 Gambler or
in West Virginia visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net in New York call
8778 hope Andy or text hope Andy 467 369
in Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 888 78977 77 or
visit ccpg dorg please play responsibly
on behalf of Boothill Casino and Resort
in Kansas 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario bonus bets
expire 168 hours after issuance cdk
ng.com for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming resources today's episode is also
brought to you by haa typical children's
vitamins are basically candy and
disguise they're filled with two
teaspoons of sugar unhealthy chemicals
other gummy junk that Growing Kids
should just not eat and that's why haa
was created the pediatrician approved
superpowered chewable vitamin While most
children's vitamins are filled with 5
grams of sugar and can contribute to a
variety of health issues haa is made
with zero sugar and zero gummy junk yet
it tastes great and is perfect for picky
eaters haa fills the most common gaps in
modern children's diets to provide the
full body nourishment our kids need with
a yummy taste that they love formulated
with the help of nutritional experts haa
is pressed with a blend of 12 organic
fruits and veggies then supercharged
with 15 essential vitamins and minerals
including vitamin D B12 C zinc folate
and many others to help support immunity
energy brain function mood concentration
teeth bones and more so ha is designed
for kids of all ages it is sent straight
to your door so parents have one less
thing to worry about so it's just like
an easy thing I feel like you can do
every day get in a good routine with
your kids my nieces and nephews that
Kayla she loves that High Health we've
worked out a special deal with high for
their bestselling children's vitamin
receive 50% off your first order to
claim this deal you must go to High
health.com toast this deal is not
available on the regular website only
when you go to h i y a h a
l.com toast and get your kids the full
body nourishment that they need to grow
into healthy adults High health.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by Thrive Market Thrive Market is
our go-to for all of our grocery and
household essentials and the convenience
of getting everything online and then
quickly Shi to our doorstep is a huge
timesaver I know Jackie in particular
you know feeding that big family of
viers huge family it's not easy and you
know I like to be healthy because I'm
super super healthy and Thrive Market
makes that so easy I mean I'm at this
point I'm getting like weekly deliveries
from Thrive Market it's so nice to not
have to drive to the grocery store nor
lug heavy things home like they sell
reo's tomato sauce market like don't
have to carry that it's a beautiful
thing we get all of our snacks cooking
ingredients like all of our spices from
Thrive Market it's just the best place
to be shopping and you got to you got to
join I'm I'm sick of it and when you
join when you join Thrive Market you're
also helping a family in need with their
one forone membership matching program
so you basically join and they will give
you can join in on the savings with
Thrive market today and get 30% off your
first order plus a free $60 gift when
you go to thrivemarket.com
theeast for 30% off your first order
plus you'll get that free $60 gift at
Thrive
market.com theeast thrivemarket.com
theeast and just know that as a Thrive
Market member you are saving money on
every single grocery order on average we
are saving over 30% each time they even
have a deals page that changes daily and
always has some of our favorite Brands
so thrivemarket.com
theeast check it out thank you la you're
welcome next up last night Taylor Swift
announced her new studio album called
the tortured poets Department she
announced it during her acceptance
speech for pop vocal album and it comes
out on April 19th she said that she has
been working on this for two years and
she was excited to announce it to the
world no I mean we're excited too A lot
of people thought she was going to be
announcing reputation her outfit was
giving reputation she changed her
profile picture last night black and
white which is very aesthetic Ally
reputation so we were all just kind of
waiting for that I was not expecting
this I like forgot that we could get new
music from her I feel like we've been so
wellfed from tayor Recently between
public appearances the tour performances
things like that so I forgot that like
we also like will be getting new music
and it's been a year and a half since
midnights came out like it's not
folklore Evermore Vibe no like it's a
and it's an appropriate amount of time
that she made us wait like but I just
wasn't expecting it and I like we sat on
the toast literally Friday like how how
desperately we need music about Travis
like just needing like the smallest
window insight into what it's been like
and her saying that this album is 2
years old like kill me yeah and it's
tortured poets so that's not giving you
know like Varsity fanf Fair no it's
giving Joe Owen like
aesthetically yeah and he apparently has
a group chat
with Paul mcow normal people about and
it's called the
tortured men's club the tortured men's
club so people think this is kind of a
riff on that I don't think it's going to
be a whole album Joe alln diss tracks
because I think she's so far past that
and I think it could be poetry about a
lot of different things even you know
something that she's been working on in
the last six months and I feel like in
the last two months where she hasn't
been on tour she's probably been working
on new music a lot and kind of like
tinkering things I feel like there will
be Travis messaging on this album but it
won't be the whole album that's what I
think right it's not like lover Travis's
version like that's what I need
desperately yeah and it's not I'm so
excited also just like
aesthetically this definitely feels a
little bit more um folklore ever more
than it does lover 1989 and I just feel
like recently I've really been in like
my emo T I love like Al alt tailor you
know yeah and I feel like that's what
we're getting poems which typically have
a slower Vibe and the covers kind of
like Sul Tre it's very sexy yeah so I
think it's going to be like slow down
not going to be
Bop Central in the classic sense we did
say that like Taylor's upcoming
um aesthetic is definitely going to be
like a little bit more sexy sultry smut
and I think you know this proves that we
were right it's like a very sexy you
know what's kind
of giving I feel like you're not going
to see what I'm saying but if I had to
like think of like a direction and like
of a sound almost with the pictures and
what we've seen like kind of like Ariana
Grande in terms of like the breathy
vocals sexy Vibes wait you just reminded
me of something Best New Artist last
night going to um Victoria mon a lot of
people like were hoping that it was
going to be Noah Khan and they were like
really mad cuz it was like the year of
Noah Khan for sure but I love someone
getting their flowers like honestly not
enough people know about Victoria Mona
she's literally like a Julia Michaels
like Julia Michaels literally wrote
songs for other people sang for other
people did everything for other people
and then finally like had her moment and
I feel like that's happening with
Victoria mon I'm actually really happy
for her so I'm okay with it who did she
sing for like she didn't sing for but
she really like who did she write Ariana
Grande like during like those few years
where Ari was like doing the most like
that was really like a lot of it was
Victoria Monet and Ari was posting like
so happy for you yeah like a lot of Ari
success has to do with her collab
collaboration with Victoria Monae so
it's nice to see someone like having
their own moment that is nice and that's
what she was saying in Her speech she's
like I've been in this industry for 15
years and she's so young I was like how
old is this person Claudia I was
thinking the same thing I I was like she
looks so young I didn't know that she
had all these years under her belt as
being like a behind the scenes person I
didn't know any of this so thank you for
sharing yeah I'm happy for her like and
I need everyone like being like no I
can't like calm down yeah like he'll be
fine he'll he is fine he is f he's fine
it's just like a nice award to win yeah
and she was so excited it was a really
nice speech and it was also a
stacked category like jelly roll noon
ice spice
yeah like it was it was competitive yeah
sorry back to Taylor usually is back oh
so what did you think about my call that
like a little
Ari
feeling I don't like the call I know you
don't like it but do you like I'm not
saying I'm not saying that like I'm
saying if that's the the reality like I
don't like that not that it's a bad call
okay oh okay you're just in your AR
hater era which is fine I don't think
that I am she just like posted a picture
today that I really liked so so now I'm
like forgetting about SpongeBob okay
okay I get it and she's really doing the
most for her new album coming out and
she's like feeding the people yeah and
I'm starting to fall for it a little bit
I'm kind of just like a mainstream Josie
and the Pussycats brainwashed can't
think for myself
pop co uh consumer yeah 1,000% like I am
today I love that next like iteration
for you you know
yeah just tired of reading too much into
stuff like it's so true inject my
beliefs into my veins just
enjoy I'm just along for the ride people
yeah yeah who's who else should I like
then oh like industry plant energy
yeah a lot of people were saying Laney
Wilson is an industry plant she won
again last night which like Loki was
crazy I also think that the nominees for
best country album like were bad so like
I don't know how you can nominate the
best country albums and not include Luke
Holmes or Morgan Wallen who literally
sold like a million copies of their like
it's just insane it's insane and it
didn't matter who won because the real
people weren't nominated like how Luke
wasn't I mean Morgan wall and to but
like the way you guys know how I feel
about Luke's album
like what no question mark where are you
no and it's like I hope they felt dumb
after last night when it's like Luke
stole the show Luke represented country
music everybody loves Luke everybody
loves Luke and he was so gracious even
though he was so thoroughly snubbed on
every count so true that's a gracious
King that he still came and supported
their little show that's my gracious
King right
there that's my gracious King right
there okay so tortured poet's Department
MH April 19 get like a single or
something April 19th an important day in
toast her she has got to stop sh like
making the lead single the worst song on
the album it's got to stop like
anti-hero being representative of
midnights is a travesty no like when
when
youd when you hear the bridge to Dear
reader like how you like it's insane I
completely agree but that's Taylor's
formula it's worked for her for many
many years that's what she does always
we are never getting back together I
knew you in trouble the worst most corny
pop songs always are her lead singles
cuz they get played on the radio it's
the formula of the music industry like
there's a reason why she does it but
it's annoying as [__] there's no reason
why Mastermind couldn't have been that
song no I think there is a reason let me
let me let me present a couple others
quickly if I may I mean you're on your
own
kid
yeah so many songs for midnights could
have been the lead question
no I guess a lot of the ones I like are
sad oh what did you think about Taylor
Swift like making Lana Del R come up on
stage with her to accept her award it
was weird yeah because I didn't really
like Lana was nominated in that category
so she just lost she had just lost it's
giving like I can't go anywhere without
my best friend you know yeah but she
like was on stage ready with Jack and
Claire like all the girlies yeah who was
the woman Claire that's like her audio
girly and she has been working together
with her for a while like if you look at
when she won folklore she was on stage
with her too okay she's like a sound
mixer engineer something like that cool
cool cool
yeah um yeah I guess but Lana Del R
don't forget is on midnights yeah you
know she's a collaborator so like I
there's a tie in but you could tell she
like didn't want to go yeah but was it
cuz she had lost her because she didn't
want to make like tayor she was don't
being not being like hey look at me cuz
she doesn't see very hey look at me no
not at
all
yeah I don't know yeah it was
interesting okay well that's now our
final Grammy have any other thoughts on
tailored
no but I if I do you know I'll share
them throughout the week are you ready
for our next story yeah going back to
one of our favorite subjects I just feel
like we're like I in the words of the
kids like we we ate today with these
stories because this could be a whole
another episode she said we ate today
with these stories okay we're eating
good okay contro sorry I'm not going to
read this propag again headline Joe
Rogan signs a new deal with Spotify for
reported 200 and what was the headline
controversial controversial podcast host
Jo I'm sorry like biggest [__]
podcast in the world Joe Rogan signs
another deal with Spotify for reported
up to $250 million this is also crazy
because it's not an exclusive to Spotify
deal the show will be distributed
everywhere so they're just like paying
for the pleasure of Hosting him yeah
that's really crazy like the well it's
actually not crazy that they
renegotiated his contract like I think
it was a very good invest for them many
years ago what the $100 million to
Spotify is not a lot of money and them
you know renewing his contract isn't
crazy the amount is really crazy but
also the amount while also he's going to
be able to put some of his videos on
YouTube you're going to be able to
listen to the podcast like on other
platforms that's really crazy yeah also
it's crazy in light of the fact that
Spotify has wound down their podcast
department and the messaging has sort of
been
like we are channeling our efforts
elsewhere but like for Joe Rogan
obviously his investment was such a
success that they're like tripling it
and giving him more freedom oh and this
is in light of all the controversy
surrounding Joe Rogan where at a time it
was like a Spotify going to drop him
artists leaving the platform the
employees the artists were who left the
platform and it's like oh no he's making
us so much money that we don't even care
about all of that and guess what we're
going to do it again no but also like
situations like that like are net net
are good for a podcast like it's like
press is good press people are going to
tune in what's Everyone crying about
yeah especially good for a podcast like
Joe Rogan where it is his brand to not
really care you know it's not like he's
a press darling it's like oh I'm getting
bad press sorry s back yeah yeah yeah no
it's a very Renegade it's very Renegade
energy right but no this is just like
the proof is in the putting sort of
thing because everybody can like have
all their opinions and write all their
open letters but at theend end of the
day like he's making bank for them and
that's so crazy $250 million this is the
biggest podcast
contract time yeah and we don't even
know the first of all it's this is one
of those that it's reported so it's like
yeah and I do feel like with the $100
million contract last time it wasn't the
full story I think he was making a lot
more than that yeah yeah and it was like
who was selling his ads who's making the
ad of money does he get 250 million just
to have Spotify on the name of his show
but he also makes his ad revenue and
Spotify is just selling his ads no no
they keep the ad Revenue no I don't
think they do Claudia I think they do we
don't know for sure but my guess is that
they don't and your guess is that they
do oh my guess is that they W 100% do my
guess is that it's a rep share no no no
no they're paying for the for the
privilege of of your
show and like all that comes with it
that's what I really think but like in
the deal just got even like looser than
the last one well this one I don't know
yeah this deal is like
nuts yeah this deal is like Joe Rogan
please just like say the name Spotify
once and we'll give you Millions yeah
literally it's just very interesting to
get paid such a hefty sum and not have
your show be exclusive on Spotify yeah
that's really crazy so he'll be back on
the charts slugging it with the rest of
us [__] it was fun being number one and
two for a while it was fun Joe [__]
between guess we'll go back to be number
three
big time but it's also he puts out so
many episodes so he just like congests
the whole top 10 by the way so do we
that's what people think about us like
we're all over the charts because we
have so many episodes okay I love that
for us we're kind of like The Joe Rogan
of like Pup Culture you
know yeah totally totally I'm happy for
him like on the fact that like money is
still being spent on podcast is so great
for the industry great for the medium
happy for him know that I am wish it was
me happy for you
yeah and he he's great for the industry
he is the industry it's true but no I
think he sets great president and he
doesn't back down and you know what and
he still gets paid true the proof is in
the pudding and if people listen to your
show they're going to pay you if people
so true so I think it's all good me too
are you ready for our fifth and final
story Switching gears yes I am candy
burus exits real houses of Atlanta after
14 Seasons saying I'm not coming back
this year this is end of an era type
[__] yeah the longtime real housers of
Atlanta Star revealed at the 2024 Grammy
Awards on Sunday that she's exiting the
Bravo reality show after 14 consecutive
Seasons I decided I'm not coming back
this year she told variety on the red
carpet it's been 14 seasons and they
allowed us to sit around for a little
too long but during that time I started
working on a lot of other things and
they've got some nice big projects
coming soon so I'm super excited about
those
things I
mean crazy first of all like she's so OG
her announcement was so lowkey like No
statement no press release just like on
the red carpet being asked and she's
like yeah I'm not coming back very
lowkey not shocking the franchise has
fallen off yeah and she's one I think of
the last remaining o OG's like shereé
has come and gone Marlo wasn't fulltime
Nene left so she's definitely I think
one of the last it's time it's the end
of an era but like it's sad but she
wasn't on season one she wasn't no I
don't remember her being on season one
candy
buris real never mind I just I consider
her like a she is like an
OG but is she
not what season did K oh she joined in
the second season okay I'm sorry like
that's an OJ yeah yeah yeah no it's an
OG in
colloquially yeah and she I just like
consider her she's like a backbone of
that franchise but the franchise has
fallen off
they need like a big restructure like
they did with New York but I don't know
if that necessarily even worked out um
so it is her time and she's I feel like
she'll continued to do like girls trip
because she just did a girls trip that
people love she has her show on the
network right which one uh
candies she has had like a bunch of
spin-offs I don't know if she currently
has any she had like a wedding special
she had one with her band Escape I
thought she had one with her family she
did she did I don't know if it's still
on got it
okay yeah she has a lot candy and the
Gang she's she has had she had like the
old lady gang with her mom like she has
a lot going on I'm not worried about her
like you know business-wise Candy ski
trip yeah she's had like a million wait
I I have to watch that spin-offs yeah
that's hysterical end of an
era end of an era so so those are the
fast five stories you absolutely needed
to know them because it was a big it was
a big weekend in pop culture it's going
to be a big week and then we have the
Super Bowl this weekend so you guys stay
dressed and stay alert anything can
happen I really really hope I'll be back
in studio tomorrow I'm going to the
doctor today so pray for your girl yeah
just take it easy I know like make a
soup have your husband make you a soup
asterik than you guys so much for
listening to the toast Monday Morning
Show where we deliver the fast five
stories you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give us a thumbs up
we're also available as podcast anywhere
podcast can be found spot of iTunes
public radio all plac podcast a
beautiful setting and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow love you
bye